qui a tué a tué Marianne Kubala et
Robert drouvain l'affaire remonte à 2004
à Vernou-sur-Brenne faute d'éléments
l'enquête sur le meurtre de ce couple
d'octogénaire avait été classé sans
suite mais elle pourrait bien rebondir
le nouveau pôle national dédié aux
affaires non élucidées en effet rouvert
le dossier Audrey Champigny revient pour
nous sur ce call case en effet bien
mystérieux
au matin du lundi 9 août 2004 Robert
Drouvin et retrouvé mort dans son jardin
son corps dissimulé sous une bâche
quelques mètres plus loin un deuxième
corps est étendu face contre terre celui
de Marianne Kubala la scène de crime il
est coupé au visage du vieil homme
écarte rapidement la piste du suicide sa
compagne elle serait morte de peur on
sait que l'auteur était retourné dans la
maison il y avait de la poudre
d'extincteur qui était qui avait été
déversé par tout sans doute parce que
Robert Drouin s'était servi de
l'extincteur pour se défendre l'auteur
avait effacé la plupart des traces sauf
qu'il y avait quand même des traces de
pas donc tout qui était quand même
relativement précise et qui s'est avéré
en fait correspondre à une paire de
chaussures
qui n'était qui était assez peu
courantes qui est un fabricant qui
coulait très peu en France et donc il y
a que quelques pairs qui a été vendu
dont une